alors Dave 50 ans de carrière 17 albums
5 livres mais moi ce qui m'intéresse
surtout c'est c'est assez incroyable
c'est que aujourd'hui Dave j'allais dire
Adamo Sardou Lama faites partie de ces
noms tout le monde vous connaît toutes
les générations quand on a fait nous on
veut venir des gens et tout ça je vous
le dis tout le monde vous connaît voilà
quand même pas je vous promets que c'est
assez marrant quand j'ai fait incroyable
talent quand les mamans a amené leur
monde savais que c'était grâce à
l'incroyable talent oui et quand c'est
plus les chansons donc ça c'est normal
quand on pense qu'un Radio Nostalgie
commence avec les années 80 des Brassens
Brel Aznavour ça passe plus nulle part
mais c'est triste non c'est passé des
bonnes chansons
j'aimerais prendre de vos nouvelles
personnel la petite personnelle parce
que le 28 janvier enfin 2022 pardon vous
avez été 3 jours dans le coma lourd de
chute chez vous
je ne suis pas ni ceux qui préparent les
filles
vous êtes tombés dans votre appartement
je suis tombé et je me suis renseigné
après un fois que j'ai donc en effet 4G
comment et un mois à l'hôpital mais
c'est quand même eu le temps de me
renseigner un peu il y a 20 environ
20000 accidents dans le dans chez les
gens donc comment on appelle ça accident
domestique merci
et
60% en plus de 60 ans donc ça me
concerne pas encore mais bien sûr
vous êtes tombés chez vous je suis tombé
en arrière je ne me souviens strictement
de rien vraiment de rien et j'ai pas
hâte de me rappeler mais mon compagnon
avant je dis ça l'a vraiment traumatisé
parce que lui il a vécu ça bien sûr
c'est terrible quand on sait qu'il y a
autant d'accident que ça ils peuvent
tout simplement pas un appel c'est un
truc pour soutenir quand on monte en
Espagne
et vous m'avez dit derrière en plus que
le plus dur pour vous c'est que vous
avez perdu le goût ça c'est pas le covid
c'est la chute ah c'est pas le covid si
touche du bois
ouais ça c'est pas revenu
mais là je peux vous demander je peux là
je peux vous filer n'importe quoi à bord
vous y a rien il y a pas de rien là
c'est une Suze vous les goûter rien non
ça
s'use une solution donc ça veut dire que
tous les jours vous massez des trucs
il faut vraiment pas rigoler parce que
dans le cas je sais que beaucoup de gens
à cause du covid parfois 10 jours mais
il y a des cas où ça du plus de non et
c'est absolument insupportable quand on
ne serait-ce que légèrement
attaché à ce genre de plaisir c'était à
mon âge on juge depuis tellement
autrement au moins à la bouffe et un bon
verre de vin tout ça rien rien quand je
fais les courses j'adore faire les
courses quand je vais il serait ce qu'on
va télécharger l'huile d'olive je
l'achète pas parce que il veut pas le
goûter vraiment très très simple et
souvent tu sais pas quand est-ce que ça
va s'arrêter ou revenir
alors moi je connais un cas je l'ai pas
perçu je l'ai croisé une fois à Venise
une chanteuse très célèbre au Pays-Bas
que vous connaissez pas qui a des gens
de Juliette Gréco qui était donc elle a
une action de voiture très donc comme
moi en hémorragie cérébrale 17 ans ça a
duré ah donc ça m'amène quand même
presque 80 ans
vous allez retrouver mais
un jour puis en plus c'est pas de bol
après on arrête de parler des trucs mais
comme dans 2011 vous avez opération à
cœur ouvert vous vous faites une petite
décennie sympathique non c'est pire que
ça parce que donc ça on parle de 25
janvier donc exactement non j'ai envie
de l'année d'avant on a Patrick c'est
mon mec on est pas failli crever tous
les deux par le monoxyde de carbone dans
le même faut peut-être que je change de
village peut-être de l'hôpital aussi
c'est important de dire ça c'est
quelqu'un prenez un système d'alarme
parce que vous l'avez pour les gaz mais
les gaz ça ne sent rien parce qu'on lui
a coupé le gazon
et vous crevez et vous savez ce qui m'a
sauvé quelque part non quand ça m'est
arrivé je suis tombé donc encore un peu
et là qu'est-ce qui m'arrive et je
pensais à un livre Annie Duperey qui a
perdu ses deux parents à l'âge de 8 ans
qu'elle a trouvé morte dans la salle de
bain à cause de mon anxiété carbone
aussi